[Music]
the Coast Guard Cutter PolarStar is the
most powerful icebreaker in the world
our mission is to cut a channel that's
18 miles long through 8 to 12 feet of
ice so that the supply ships can
resupply the continent this is where we
earn our money
the ship is 40 years old older than most
of the people onboard
Rinspeed 10 knots ready first start i'm
lieutenant junior grade Morrison I'm the
fueling officer aboard and the auxiliary
division officer the Polar Star is
America's only heavy icebreaker and it
is the only one that can break that
channel so I've got the entire continent
relying on me I have to turn that ice
and ice cubes about to make our approach
on the fast ice which is McMurdo Sound
it's a solid ice from shore to shore has
no relief when we go to break them most
boats don't like to go through even a
thin layer of ice and we're going
through the six-foot chunks of ice
continuously back up this Polarstern 1/6
over main control is the brain or
epicenter for the engineering propulsion
plant ok Roger when we break guys
it's like imagine 10 12 Richter scale
earthquake to be on board during that
experience just imagine yourself in an
earthquake for a week non-stop
this goes against all sensin seamanship
and navigation looking behind you when
you're driving a ship we preach to our
young ship handlers to always look
forward but they look behind us make
sure we're driving in a straight line
which makes it a lot easier for the
supply ship to navigate in when we
escort them it's much more practical and
efficient to look behind you try to keep
it straight we don't have to worry about
other contacts and other ships up here
the ice channel is the lifeblood to
Antarctica and the flow science missions
the young men and women down below deck
sacrificed their time with their
families and holiday seasons they work
night and day to make sure the ship
stays under way that those propellers
keep turning I'm very very proud of
these young people we are at six knots
it's pretty amazing to see what they can
do
[Music]
[Music]